[Music]
my name is 8-track I'm a DJ producer
record label owner
it's sort of like science of DJing if
you try to boil it down too much to
assemble the description of
beat-matching for example definitely
like a an intangible to it on a very
simple level be meshing is what you call
matching the temple of one song to the
next song that's playing so that you
have a continuous beat and you know just
going back to the basic idea that DJ's
keep people dancing you're able to keep
the tempo steady as you go from song to
song it's actually a pretty easy
technique but DJing itself is not that
easy and I think the real role of the DJ
is selection it's picking songs and
having a sense of what to play and win
and that's the part that's harder to
break down or explain what really
differentiates a good DJ from a
not-so-good DJ is selection and taste
and sense of timing and also knowing how
to adapt to different rounds that's
probably the biggest thing that DJ's
have to learn is to you know understand
not only what's a plan and when but in
which setting you can't play the same
set everywhere electronic music been
around since the late 70s early eighties
so electronic music isn't new but EDM is
this newer bigger more polished
manifestation of it and when it really
broke in America at the beginning of
this decade it's also when certain songs
were really bonafide pop songs and we're
playing on the radio new audiences
embraced these big records that had a
universal appeal and by the same token
embraced the producers and DJs who were
behind those records more and more of
these festivals started popping up I
think that confused a lot of people just
seeing a DJ essentially play songs that
were already made on the stage where
they'd be used to seeing the Red Hot
Chili Peppers
something many people were questioning
whether DJ's were really just pressing
play and I became a bit of a buzz word
pressing play button pusher the range of
different styles that started existing
got almost too big to just categorize
this one thing so do some DJ's just go
up and press play and pulling in the
same set add a lot of events yeah does
that mean that all DJ's do that no a lot
of DJ's have true craftsmanship and arts
of what they do usually the argument
that most people will give and that I
was just giving also that DJ's don't
really play the same set everywhere and
we're mixing live and all this stuff but
in some cases when the show is so big
that you get into a place where there
actually is literally pyro and you know
effects that need to be time then
there's a net then you'll still have a
DJ who plans their sit but even that to
me can be compared to theater when you
go watch theater it's it's a pre-planned
but it's great entertainment in the case
of the DJ the DJ's doing a sort of meson
sin of songs that they know the crowd
will enjoy hearing and songs that they
are sometimes connected to or that they
made and translating that into a show
that will work in front of 60,000 people
there's an art to that too
[Applause]
the control of energy is kind of magical
and undeniable and that's a big part of
the art - so between that and you know
the sort of sonic wizardry that happens
with the knobs on here it definitely
isn't something to be diminished